jack mc call aurait dit n'importe quoi
pour parvenir à ses fins
alors à la gauche matin mais comment
c'est tellement plus que l'un d'eux
merci
mais il n'aurait pas dû vous allez
vraiment publier mon livre mais
évidemment voyons vous avez ma parole
monsieur mentir à cet homme là bas notre
sort est désormais lié à celui de cet
arbre saluera il tombe à chaque mot que
vous prononcez je vais à mega burger
avec la clape l'un des maillons du bacon
et une double portion de frites dans un
arbre vert s'est fait qu'est-ce que cela
signifie
je vais crever alors il me reste quoi
mais le mot à dire est ce qu'on peut en
discuter les termes des contrats vous
conviennent un trip expression de la
terre
l'ate est classé un supplément de l'est
pourquoi tu t'exprimes part j'ai restant
grognant tu pourrais être un poulain
pour moi chaque mot que nous prononçons
exerce une influence à l'échelle de
l'univers
c'est à moi de parler je joue votre rue
arrêtez je suis pas te b je fais pas la
manche sortez-moi de l'eau je suis à un
run with burger respecte mon
intelligence gars vous êtes en ajax
contrôle tout baigne
vous le dirai quand je peux traverser
d'ailleurs c'est bon merci gilles
réseaux sont autant pas de mots